so yes hello everyone good afternoon my
name is Chris and because I love
functional programming I will be talking
about MVC pattern because obviously
those two things works well together my
name is Chris I'm from Poland usually
when I talk about myself I call myself
open-source maintainer might be
open-source contributor but yesterday
philip carter who just did talk on this
stage called me OSS troublemaker and i
really like it it sounds nice so let's
go with that
for those of you who don't know me I'm
like active member of a flop community
maintaining ionised plugin which also
philip has mentioned in his talk which
is set of plugins for Visual Studio code
that gives you ID like experience in
Visual Studio code it's really good
I'm also maintainer of couple of other
smaller project and recently I've
started I've created new new project
that I will be talking about it's called
sattanna but we'll get to this point
later yes before we go go and forward
this is controversial topic just because
there's couple of different web
frameworks and web libraries in in F
sharp web space and people are really
opinionated about how stuff should look
like so yes it's this this this talk and
subtly in general is some my my personal
vision on how web programming can look
like with F sharp and warning number two
is I don't know enough about web sharper
so I just want to be talking about web
sharper web sharper is really cool
project from what I understand that
enables you to run code both in in
server and in front end it's really nice
it's one of the solutions that enables
you to do that with F sharp it's pretty
old project with commercial support so
feel free to check it out and there is
one main reason why I'm actually doing
this talking
one main reason why I'm interested in
web programming with a shop in general
web in really in principle is functional
especially HTTP protocol HTTP protocol
can be modeled as a function that takes
HTTP requests and threatens HTTP
response and that's all this is the
spline function it might have some side
effects it may not have some side and
side effects but in the end we send
requests we get back response from the
server so if this is just a function you
could think that functional programming
language should work pretty well with
this model F sharp is functional
programming language we are in
functional programming track here Oh so
yeah let's let's talk about that and for
couple of years they have been few
libraries that focus on web programming
with F sharp and the main one for a
while was swath and then giraffe is
basically implementation of same
programming model that soif do on top of
asp.net core to enable us to do really
cool stuff and integration with asp.net
core and get all this amazing
performance benefits that asp.net core
team is so proud of which is very cool
before before going any further actually
it is this I've lied to you this this
HTTP request returning HTTP response is
not really everything that server needs
to know that's that was point of view of
like external client like JavaScript
library that calls just some code and
and waits to get back some response but
from server point of view we need
something else and this is something we
need something more and this is usually
called HTTP context it's called a bit
different in different libraries let's
not focus on that let's call it HTTP
context and HTTP context contains a
couple of informations not only just
HTTP requests so it contains HTTP
requests but it contains also
the current state of HTTP response and
it contains some any additional
information about for example server and
a global state if you have any so yes we
model it right like that and the second
important concept is the thing called
web part web part is the name taken from
suave in giraffe it's called HTTP
handler in giraffe it's bit more complex
than that but in principle web part is a
function that takes context and may so
we have this option type so it's my
result new HTTP context or may not
result in new HTTP context and in
principle it's async operation does it
may take a while so it's pretty obvious
to be to make it a sink operation
especially under 30 we can have
multi-threading so making stuff running
on as an icing makes sense yes and for
those of you who has been on scott scott
slash in talk tomorrow today morning
Scott's in the end of his talk he
actually used suave as an example of
function composition and we have two
main ways of composing web parts
together first one is is this funky
operator it it's the rocket operator and
functional programming programmers
usually call it bind well it's not
actually a bind but let's not not go too
deep into that it takes two different
web parts and produces one web part out
of those two so what it does it takes
HTTP context it evaluates first web part
if first web part return and some so it
returns result it pushes this result of
the first web part into second web part
if it failed it just returns none so
this is the example of the power of
composition that Scott was talking in
the morning about so that's that's the
first operation and second one is is
choose Combinator and choose Combinator
takes
list of webpart also return a single
webpart and it buys the clay checks
different web parts one by one from top
so we go to choose we have waste we go
to first element of list we check if
route is pink if it is with a turn punk
if the route returns no no because it's
route is not pink then we go to second
and we check if route is nothing and we
can get back have many many of those
those cases what's super nice about that
it is the fact that it works well
together so both both rocket operator
and choose returns web part so we can
compose again retro result of one
binding one choose with other web parts
so we can create those pretty complex
applications with this composition that
functional programming is all about and
if you like squeeze a bit and look at
that it kind of creates decision tree of
what's going on in your application it's
not decision tree per se but we check we
go to web part we check if it's good if
it's good then we make another decision
if it's not good we go to the post we
check if it's post if it's post we make
some other decisions and so on so on so
on so this is this is very nice model
and again the warning don't get me wrong
this model is really good I've been
using I've been using swap for years
with with after up in both open source
and commercial product I've been using
JIRA for the last couple of months in
both open stores and commercial products
and it's this is really really nice
model the power of this model is first
of all it's super simple so you
literally needs to know those two
operations so the rocket operator and
choose function to create any possible
decision free the decision tree you want
to do in your
vacation secondly this model is really
powerful and it's really flexible
because you can using those those those
operations you can do whatever you want
you can model anything that's correct
according to HTTP protocol and even you
can do stuff that's not really related
with HTTP protocol but the model and
yeah before going through some problems
I've seen people that have done nothing
with web programming we were able to
learn this model in like one week and be
productive with it and create
applications that right now are running
on millions of for millions of users
well maybe hundreds of thousands of
users so this is really good but the
model has a couple of problems and this
is like my opinionated stuff so for me
it doesn't scale well with size of the
application so yes you can compose you
can you can create names for parts of
the of your application and then compose
it using names because yes functions are
first class citizen enough sharp so we
can pass them around but for me it's not
very direct if you have big big
application with 40 controllers like
rest controllers which has like every
rest controller have like 6 endpoints
for a different web for different what
were for different verbs in HTTP
protocol and different like endpoints
with ID or not ID this is growing
massively and I mean it's growing
massively and I've seen such code bases
and such code bases are not really nice
to work with it's pretty low level so
yes it's really powerful it's really
flexible but it means it doesn't really
provide those like it doesn't have
batteries included you need to build
everything on your own step by step if
you return JSON from your API you need
to remember to start content type to
application / day sauna if you get
requests you need to manually check if
it's if it's content type JSON if it's
content type XML or whether it's
something different and and you must
manually encode this logic and usually
we are familiar with web frameworks are
like asp.net like Ruby on Rails like
Phoenix in case of a leak zero
and there are solving this problem for
us so so yeah and last thing is it
doesn't provide structure or maybe to
say it a bit differently it doesn't
provide you a bit of success mark Simon
is doing great talks about functional
architecture and he is always saying
about this bit of success concept when
language features or language rket or
architecture that's pushed into you by
the language causes you to make good
architecture automatically so you don't
need to work hard to make things well
you just follow the path of least the
easiest path and and you will end up
with good architecture suave and this
model doesn't provide you that because
you could combine it what what however
you want you can do some crazy stuff and
because of that it's error-prone because
you can accidentally may I do some wrong
composition and do check that takes
really long time or some operation that
takes really long time and accidentally
plug it on top of your application and
it will be run for every endpoint
instead maybe it should be run only for
one endpoint and there is nothing that
will stop you to doing anything crazy
like that and it's easy to make such
mistakes especially if you're new to
technology you don't have lot of
experience with the technology and also
it doesn't provide fully any patterns
related to how to structure code how to
structure your project how to structure
your solution
and if you think about that those
patterns are actually important because
what you want to do as a software
developer is you don't want to focus on
modeling your web server collect
correctly you don't want to focus on
building on modeling HTTP server
thinking about how to structure code you
just want to write business code and
earn money for your company as a result
of writing business code or lose money
for your company dependents depending on
what you want to do so on the other hand
in especially in object-oriented
programming languages we have this pink
called MVC pattern and it's really
really popular of really successful
asp.net MVC Ruby on Rails Django well
it's not MVC per se but it's similar
so in MVC pattern we have model which is
represented by some classes we have
viewer which more classes and then we
obviously have controller as names
address that here classes again and
probably you're right now thinking hey
Chris you're and functional programming
track we don't want to hear about
classes yes but this model this pattern
has couple of advantages it's usually
high level model so you create
controller and controller handles for
your routing you just create some maybe
put attribute if you want to modify
something but usually all those
frameworks has some kind of conventions
that work out of the box and you just
write your business domain code they
provide structure so we know that you
need to put viewers into view folder or
whatever this is bit silly but they do
and this enables them to provide great
tooling around around them so it enables
developers to create scaffolding tooling
that you do right-click in visual studio
create new controller and this
controller will this finger will not
create only controller but it will also
like create entity favored context from
for you
and connection to database and
everything and some default views and
everything will work out of the box
magically and I know that maybe it's not
super popular but I actually think it's
good good thing because it enables new
people to to learn framework really fast
because they don't need need to think
about those details it enables you to be
really productive those framework has
usually one big drawback so there is no
easy way to fall back to lower level
usually there is away but you usually
it's really like tricky so you need to
override some classes or implement some
magical interface and plug it somewhere
in the start up with various p.net for
example and no one but asp.net team
knows exactly how it works so the
question is can we do better than any of
those Sina scenarios and I guess the
answer is obviously yes because
otherwise I wouldn't be standing here in
front of you let's imagine a perfect
world in which we have a again MVC
pattern but our model is not some some
random classes with some mutable state
but it's immutable model and pure
function that operates under on them
that's pretty standard like for
functional programming this is nothing
nothing really amazing view view is a
function that takes model and maybe some
additional context and returns HTML this
should be like pure function without any
side effects just return HTML as a
string or any other representation
that's working in context of your
application and then a controller may be
just a function that takes set of pure
functions and wrap them together in
opinionated way using some kind of
convention just like MVC frameworks
usually do and here it comes to the to
my project called Saturn Saturn is how I
describe this it's opinionated framework
built on top of giraffe and asp.net core
that implements MVC pattern in
functional programming way which is a
lot of buzzwords but first of all it's
implemented on top of giraffe giraffe
it's implemented on top of asp.net car
this means that we have access to this
huge ecosystem of asp.net color
libraries asp.net extensions not only
from Microsoft but also from huge
c-sharp community which is really really
important and it's not really a case
we've swap for example one basically
swath leaves in its own ecosystem yes it
integrates with existing ecosystem
Saturn one of the aims of the Saturn is
also provide additional tooling so if
anyone of you follows me on Twitter you
may know that I have this like developer
experience and tooling fascination and
I've been for the last couple of years
I've been doing a lot of stuff in this
space a lot of open source stuff and I
really really think that having good
developer tools is really important part
of the success of some of those
frameworks it's not only about API
design it's not only about code quality
it's not only about performance but it
in huge huge part it's about how easy
you can start with the framework and how
easy junior developer will be able to
join your team and be productive in your
in context of your team and your
application in principle Saturn provides
higher level abstractions on top of
giraffe model so instead of using those
binds and choose manually to compose
applications we have couple of
higher-level building blocks that will
enable you to just write your business
again business domain not focusing on on
this stuff that in my opinion should be
handled automatically by you what's
really nice about that is I've written
here that those are higher level
abstractions but usually if we talk
about higher level abstractions in in in
programming languages we think about
some class some additional class on top
of other class or some some something
else but actually I've I'm using one of
the features of f-stop that's pretty
unique called computation expressions
and I'm using really not really
well-known feature of this computation
expressions to compile them down during
application startup or maybe during even
compilation time rather to those
low-level building blocks so I will show
you in a moment couple of apps of those
abstractions and all those abstractions
are actually compiled down to the web
parts or to the HTTP handles how it's
called in in in giraffe which means that
you can easily take something I call
controller come it automatically
compiles down to normal HTTP Condor and
you can easily plug it with your lower
level a giraffe application existing gdf
application with bank functional with
choose function nothing stops you two
nothing stops you from that so this is
really powerful model because and also
other way around
all my abstractions enables you to plug
existing HTTP handlers or plug those
lower-level giraffe type HTTP handlers
what parts so it actually we operate on
the same abstraction level but we have
higher level building blocks this might
not make a lot of sense but that's how I
like to describe it so this is pretty
unique because you don't need to do
anything special to fall back to lower
level like you need to do in in asp.net
core in Ruby on Rails you just go back
to writing giraffe code and if you want
to do higher level stuff you would go to
writing Saturn code and it integrates
without any problems it also hides ugly
parts of giraffe and that don't get me
drunk like she'd office an amazing
library I love it what I don't love
about it is that it's
well what I both love and hate about ZF
is that it sits on top of asp.net car
and asp.net car is amazing technology
but it has a couple of problems
especially if you use it from from F
sharp so asp.net core has been clearly
designed with C sharp in mind especially
stuff like configuration and all those
dependency injection that's built in
asp.net core that you need to register
some services to enable some features
like caching or distributed caching with
radius or or coarse support or CSRF
support all this stuff it's pretty ugly
and it's not only because of sharafa per
se but it's ugly because of asp.net core
it's not really this is not idiomatic a
trap code and giraffe was not designed
SP dotnet core was not designed with F
sharp in mind and giraffe does nothing
to hide it because that drift philosophy
yes and what's next what's next I'll go
to to some demos and those will be some
funny fun demos I hope and we need to
pray to demos gods do not kill my
machine one thing I want to I want to
tell you as too many active that's not
important no one cares
there is one figure before going to
demos actually I want to mention is if
you were on the previous talk Philip has
mentioned this ubiquitous feature full
toing that f sharp has across all
platforms and kind of to show that I am
using Linux with Visual Studio code so
let's let's hope that it works okay so
first thing we've introduced in and well
let's go back to project file project
file for Saturn is super simple you just
create console application with dot car
or the Fulton framework you add Saturn
package reference and it works
yes yes sure thanks fer is that okay
everyone on the end yes perfect so this
is normal console application you open a
system which apparently hmm
my editor tells me that it's not
necessary we open second we open 0th and
the first thing is if you haven't seen
computation expressions before
computation expression is this block of
the code that can have custom behavior
it's it's actually implemented as a
normal class in F sharp it's basically
just you have some predefined methods
you can override to modify behavior of
existing keywords such like such as let
Bank or return or do keywords but you
can also create custom keywords in
computation expressions and this is
really powerful this is used for example
in query computation expression that
comes out of the box with F sharp I
believe which enables you to write like
sequel like syntax inside of this fancy
fancy finger and basically what we what
you do is you call computation
expression then you have curly braces
and yes you can you have sometimes curly
braces in F sharp and then the code
between curly braces is magical let's
say so the first thing is this pipeline
computation expression and pipeline is
decorative why to compose set of HTTP
handlers this is basically still pretty
low-level what it does is actually under
the hood it's it's using the this rocket
magical operator main main reason to do
that is actually not really to create
this any higher level abstraction but I
have this theory that having those weird
operators is not helping adoption of the
libraries so I've decided to hide this
under the hood with this nice
declarative
in tax Sutton provides set of popular
HTTP hunters such as set header as
custom keywords in in in this
computation expression this is rate of
implementation details what's important
is that you can just go here press ENTER
to set and there is a couple of things
set bodies that status sign whatever
there are many of those and this is this
is nothing nothing really tricky what's
really nice about that is that you can
compose again as you can see this is
HTTP handler and HTTP handler as I've
mentioned before it's just what part
it's named differently in in in giraffe
but as you can see it's not really any
other new concept it's not really any
other new class new type that you need
to worry about how to compose it
together with with the other parts of
the your application it's it's
normalized EP handler that you get if
you write normal 0f application so this
is fun because those are HTTP handles
you can compose them together easily
because you can compose HTTP hundreds we
further HTTP handlers and since pipeline
compiler compiles down to the HTTP
handler then you can compose pipelines
together again we have couple of those
predefined pipelines but also and those
are those predefined pipelines that are
doing something it's not really
important what they do when it's
fetching session second one is changing
and it had requests in to get requests
because that's what usually people want
to do and the first one is it's is
adding some unique request ID to every
request you have it's not really
important what they do actually it's
just showing that you can plug anything
either what we provide out of the box in
Saturn what giraffe provides out of the
box in giraffe or custom code you've
written like this
the second concept we have is is the
thing called scope scope is bit higher
level and scope is used to define
routing for your application or sub
routing for part of your application so
basically you have keywords like get
post delete which can be used to create
the routing for this part of the
application what's really nice is that
it's it has type size formatting so
there is delete F and get F and so on
and he here in the root in the
definition of route you used percent as
percent d % e symbols and what the
framework and what AB strap is able to
do it knows that s is a string so it's
really nice because you can write your
route and it's type size that that's
that's fun the first thing before before
going to the highest abstraction
abstraction layer that I I want to show
you the first thing we do is we provide
application computation expression and
application computation expression is
bit different application computation
expression actually doesn't compile to
HTTP handler because it has totally
different different reason to be in
subtle what it does is it hides the
nasty configuration that asp.net Cora
has so as you can see we just tell it to
every we request we want to pipe through
endpoint pipe whoops we tell the with
our application which Rooter to use on
which URL we want to host it and we have
something called memory cache whatever
it is
what's nice about it is that it's
totally declarative code I mean you
don't know how under the hood this is
enabled and some of those things are
pretty nasty to configure if you don't
know what you are doing and if you're
creating new new asp.net core
application
so let's let's try to play with that
that's not that's not yes I'm terrible
at typing let's enable watch mode for
that and it has written something to us
that we are actually now listening on
port 85 80 85 application started we can
go here and yes there's hello world
that's amazing and if we go to slash a
we get other a hello world so this is
simple thing it works but that's
probably not you if imagine like you you
want those MVC partner higher level
abstractions and I have some code to
copy paste
what's copy paste at the most important
part of the Saturn is the controller
computation expression and controller
computation expression provides
opinionated way to create rest ish
controller in your application so
basically it provides set of the action
actions that you can implement such as
index Art Show edit update delete create
and I think I've missed one so and you
just focus on implementing those actions
you just focus on your business logic
that's behind those actions and what
controller computation expression does
is it puts some predefined opinionated
routing about how routing in this disk
controller should look like and this is
following standard rest conventions with
some one or two small additions so get
request to the root empty or goes to
index get request to route ID goes to
show because if you go to
HTTP if you go to www.medicare.gov
book slash 1-2-3 you want to see the
particular element of the list not all
elements and so on so on so on
what's yeah that's nice what save the
file
this is reloading this is starting and I
think I forgot about one thing and this
is this is all this is composable so you
can create new top router that some that
some requests are pointed to the other
looter that we've defined before some
requests are pointed out at controller
because we want to have API we want to
have controller we want to pipe every
request to through header pipe we have
hundreds for not found if there is no
new route that matches our routing yes
and this started so let's go back here
now this won't work because we've put it
it on the API and controller what have
we done users slash it goes to the index
handler those hundreds are pretty empty
I will in a moment I will show more
complex sample but what what what's
important in this sample is that it all
actually compares to those HTTP handlers
so as you can see this user controller
is a it's type is HTTP handler it's not
any anything magic you can compose it
with any other abstraction or any other
building block that we've introduced or
with normal building blocks from giraffe
we're just pretty cool I think the other
thing I've mentioned is that we want to
provide this tooling that creates you
that enables you to quickly start up
with with your project that enables
junior developers to understand what's
what's going on that tells you how you
should structure your application and
let's close that and go to demo too so
in in current new modern dotnet world we
have the this thing called dotnet CLI
tool dozen CLI tool has templates so
probably we can do something like that
needs new to create any application and
let's try to creates a tirana and it
actually worked almost and ignore that
part I'm using like development version
of of satin that's why it's not working
completely but it created some
application and what's open net first
thing first
it created solution file if you like
solution files so you can open it in
Visual Studio and it was there for Mac
if you don't like Visual Studio code for
some random reason you should like
visuals to the code trust me then it
created the string called packet
dependencies and if you don't know
packet is alternative nougat client
that's really popular in in f-sharp
community it's really nice there are a
couple of reasons why why packets should
be used but it's out of the scope of
this talk and probably it would take me
like another whole talk to explain why
packet is great but packet is great and
it's it's not because I think it's great
like I mean packet is default choice for
most projects most are open source
projects it also creates build script
using fake focus like build system that
provides build definition and buy build
definition I don't mean compilation
because compilation is just dotnet build
doesn't run this is probably simple but
what fake is about is about creating
those complex build processes such as oh
I need to disturb packages I need to
build then I need to start application
than I need to run the unit test and I
need to run integration tests then I
need to deploy this to CI server and
then I need to push stuff to nougat and
push stuff to
github releases whatever so it enables
you to script everything and it has like
hundreds of extensions to different
broad products in doesn't spice so it
has integration for basically everything
okay dot solution created by the by by
ethnicity Oren has two projects one is
just named exactly the same as as a
solution which is our project which
Saturn and second one is called
migrations and as you can imagine it
will contain some immigrations what may
start the application oh yes restoring
packages do I have Internet yes I do
good in the meantime what we've created
oh it worked here huh mailing the
application we've created already has a
couple of files so it has some
opinionated database database
abstraction that you can use it's based
on dapper it's just some nicer F sharp Y
of handling some things with dapper
it has config file which probably you
should if you have some configuration
you should add it here for a starter we
have we just have connection string
because that's what we generally have in
our web application we have some
connection to database we have something
called templates folder with couple of
templates which as you can imagine
describe layouts of your views it's
exactly the same if you would scaffold
the new asp.net core MVC application you
would have some reserve us out of the
box in there I believe or if you would
scaffold new Ruby on Rails application
and it has a purpose which is general
layout it has index view which is
probably your main view of application
is some some generic not found web page
it has some generic internal error web
page it also comes out of the box with
with fruit refers file which defines
some basic routing
there's one default pipeline there is
definition of default view and you
probably want to display default view
whether you go to default HTML or
index.html or empty empty route yes and
let's since it's already started let's
go back here I cannot fetch why I cannot
because I'm silly I need to add one
parameter don't watch run start that yes
and this is like the webpage that was
created it's it's beautiful right it's
using Bulma so it's good it has some
links to the documentation to the to the
github issues the guitar to two places
where you can find help
so if you're new new to the project you
just want to play with it you type that
new Saturn and you have all this
information about what you can go to say
it but that's one part that's just hello
world hello what is pink and just to
show maybe some other thing there is
like this
custom error patch and you can go back
to home page like this is this is
something all those frame will do but
that's just part of the of the of the
tooling what we also want to do is we
want to maybe create some new controller
new rest and point with views and and
showing up some some data so let's go to
Saurus demo to another part of doctor
CLI i've mentioned earlier before the
CLI enables you to create those
extensions to dot until I called CLI
tools and it's basically like custom
tool for the project that you can
execute in your product using dotnet so
we provide this thing called dot etc
adopted Saturn if you just type it it
has a couple of comments that are
possible generate the model access layer
views or maybe generate just JSON or
maybe generate model or maybe run
integration it's working progress in
general Saturn itself is pretty stable
so it's version 0.5 but but it's pretty
stable in terms of API it's not 1.0
because I just want to add more stuff to
it before going 1.0 but it's pretty
stable there shouldn't be many breaking
changes to link is in experimental stage
so it might break but it's not asking
well it's not breaking hero code so I
guess it's okay to have some braking
trainers let's generate something that's
not sat on let's generate book
controller books
ID string our string and yes I'm using
strings just on purpose because anything
calls my break so and I've tested
strings string so basically what I what
I say to the toy is that I want to
generate a new new controller called
book and we've feels like ID string out
of type string and the title of type
string and this is command line to link
but you can easily imagine that you can
have right click menu in visual studio
if that's what you like do not wear
typos why haven't you told me that I
have typos and there is some output it
generated a couple of files books model
books views book repository books
controller it updated product file it
created some migration file it updated
project migration controller generated
you need to add new controller to one of
the routes through Terezin router at
first for example yeah okay let's
copy-paste example
and let's start the application again
and why I forgot one thing what's not
start application starting application
was bad thing the another thing after
generate generating those those files
and let's let's maybe check them out so
it generated boobs model FS which is
basically play an F sharp model using
cracker type it generated some sample
really simple validation file but at
least you know how how you should
structure your application oh if I want
to add more validation to my field size
I need to put them there that's pretty
like that's pretty easy and you can just
go there write your business code it
generated a couple of views and again
this is not really important it
generated the database repository
something like repository pattern with
couple of queries and actions that can
happen with your database and by default
it's using sequel Lite and again that's
because the tooling is super
experimental and sequin light was like
easiest to have on your machine and and
I can create the sequel Lite far without
thinking about connecting to database
and stuff like that so it's also good
for demos and it created controller and
as I've mentioned controller actions are
just functions so this is normal
function this is this is what you would
write it's it's my bit but not
necessarily but it's tasks so it's like
a synchronous it's it's doing some work
so it's it's getting configuration it's
calling database and then if if database
call was successful then it renders some
some content and then it plucks it
together in the controller computation
expression it you imply in this case it
implements all the actions if you would
call the tool we've generated JSON
controller it wouldn't it wouldn't
generate the views file and it wouldn't
implement all those actions but only
that actually follows the rest
conventions and before going further I
also need to run migrations dotnet
Saturn me and this is using the supplied
library called simple migrations under
the hood
I don't know how popular this library is
but like I've done some research and it
was like I enjoyed how it works so it's
super simple and simplicity is that the
thing I value so basically to create
migration you inherit from migration
class and you overwrite two functions
one is what happens if you run
emigration and the second function is
what happens when you revert this
migration and yes I've run those
migrations in the background and it's
telling me migrating from zero empty
schema to to some version and the
version is timestamp when when the file
was created so well it's this this this
this field but it's timestamp when the
tool was run that created this this file
create table it created the typo it's
some notes fields it doesn't really
matter so much and now I can run
application
okay so that looks boring just like
before but we go to this boom yes the
books and point that I've added and as
you can see you have some predefined
view with listing books you have button
new book you can do something you add
everything is working it's actually
adding to database so you have this
scaffold of application that right now
you it may not be perfect this scaffold
is far away from being perfect but at
least you know how to start you know
where to go to modify views you know
where to go to modify your database
database connections you know where to
go if you want to add a new new
controller so that's it and but that's
that's still not it's it's fun it's it's
way more powerful than anything that
soif and JIRA provides out-of-the-box
but it's still not full capable it's
still not showing full capabilities of
Saturn controllers and full capabilities
of Saturn controls are pretty pretty
cool so Saturn controllers the thing
you've seen before so before it's
showing you just simple actions but
Saturn controllers have a couple of more
features first one is sub controllers
and sub-controllers how to explain it
well let's imagine that we have block
block engine and we have users which are
users controller which is returning
users to your client and it's on slash
users if you want to go to particular
users you do slash user slash user ID
like one two three
but this user can have some particular
comments so usually in the rest you
would do something like users slash one
two three slash comments and this would
return comments for this particular user
and that's exactly what sub controllers
are about so there are about embedding
controller into controller in again
and biased arrests ish and if anyone
really love rest and I'm totally wrong
please don't kill me
after after the Turk rest ish way so
that's one thing the second thing
controllers are super easy to version
which is really really powerful because
our application changes over at the time
and pretty often we need to maintain
different versions of our api's and to
do that actually we only need to have
one one custom keyword in the in the
controller computation expression we
with tell without it what version this
controller has and it's checking against
some custom header so I know that there
are a couple of approaches to versioning
of your api's I've decided to go with
header approach so I know a lot of
people are doing like v1 v2 in URLs I've
decided to go with with versioning
through headers and and the last thing
is you can plug particular HTTP handlers
so particular lower-level actions for
some of the of the actions if you think
about that for a moment this is really
functional way of simulating what
asp.net MVC does with any attributes and
filters actions so usually if you have
something like authorization on
controller in asp.net MVC you put
attribute outer eyes on those particular
method you want to authorize here
instead of using attributes and some
magic that that no one knows how to have
worked
we actually just plugs normal functions
into some of them and yes in this case
those are pretty simple functions
setting some some HTTP header but this
can be as well authentication function
that tells you off or index and so I
need to authenticate user and for
different actions I don't Intel
indicated oh well that would be pretty
stupid but but you know what I try to
say so yes so controllers are pretty
powerful
this versioning sub controller mechanism
and this plugging plugging plugging
actions I'm really really proud of that
because it's something that hasn't been
explored in many other frameworks and we
are happy that F sub community comes up
with these ideas and it's not all
designed by me I had also like many
contributions from community and I've
talked with many people while while
building this this framework and let's
go back to presentation because we are
running out of time what's next so as
I've mentioned right now
Saturn is Saturn's version is 0.5 and
there's a couple of things I want to do
before 1.0 release first of all I want
to implement something I call channels
and channels is abstraction of
WebSockets or over any other real-time
communication that you can have in your
web application because nowadays
applications are more and more about
real-time refreshes and real-time being
connected all the time
second thing is testing right now and
testing is both in terms of testing just
framework again if you know me and you
follow me on Twitter you know that I'm
not doing a lot of testing for my open
source projects but this is something
that I really want to be really solid
library unlike some of my other projects
the kyanite this is like aya Knight is
not important this is really important
and I want to be really saw it so first
of all I need to do some internal
testing and secondly I want to provide
some too in current testing for your
application that would use Saturn that
enables you to test controllers that
enables you to maybe and to end testing
or performance testing and or
benchmarking so this is this is really
big thing for me first thing I would
love to focus on is diagnostics and and
this is this is big tricky I don't know
how many of you remember but back then
in asp.net webforms time there was this
product called
glimpse anyone heard about glimpse okay
yes couple of you
perfect so grams was this this project
that enabled you to do some real-time
diagnostic while you were running
application in your browser so it would
open additional like some small part in
UI and would tell you this request took
so many milliseconds but it also would
tell you oh this request included
database call and this database called
call took so much milliseconds so it was
something like developer tools for web
programming in the browser but focused
on what's happening in the server which
is something really cool and and I don't
know anyone doing anything like that and
I'm really sad the project died after
Microsoft hired the outers and I haven't
said that yeah another thing I want to
focus is deeper integration with Phi
ball so Phi ball is absolute JavaScript
compiler if you don't know it's really
amazing fybel is the best thing that
happened to F strap in last couple of
years and it's really important to be to
be really deeply integrated with that
actually it's it's already partially
done by the members of the community so
there is project called fiber dot
remoting which provides type safe way of
communicating between server and Phi
ball so basically define the fan
interface and fable that remoting
automatically implement implements right
paths and write roofs both on the client
and on the server side it's super
awesome and I really recommend to check
it out and the last thing I need to
mention before before running out of
time is is this thing called safe stock
so safe stock is initiative that we've
created me Isaac Abraham staff informant
and a couple of other members of
community to popularize F sharp and to
end web programming stuck and right now
like you know this is like mean or lump
stock the people love those like
acronyms so safe is really nice because
it's suggest type safety yes so it
includes Saturn as a server it includes
Asher as a place where to host your code
or AWS it works really well with a also
but don't tell Philip that I've
mentioned AWS yeah
it includes fybel for building client
applications and in particular it
includes Elemis as this architecture of
building client-side applications that
we really believe that provides lot of
type safety and it's amazing and and I
think that we will learn more about it
tomorrow
tomorrow Friday yes that would be it
I don't think we have time for questions
so we don't really do questions in this
conference but I'm around so ask me
anything and yes again my name is Chris
you can find me on Twitter you can find
me on github you can find me on
instagram and 500px if you're interested
more in photography than these boring
programming stuff I'm having blog on
catches like that IO
I usually log sometimes once happier
well but I should I should start looking
more often I'm talking about F shut up
and open source in general so if you're
not only interested in after but also in
in some open source stuff and how open
source works feel free to check it out
I have consulting company so if you'd be
interested in any commercial support
check it out
and also again you maybe know me from
building I own I'd but I also built it
recently a couple of months ago thing
called Neptune and Neptune is plug into
visuals to the code that provides you
with super cool unit testing integration
and again this is bringing the features
of full id like visual studio into
visuals to the code with f-sharp so you
have test Explorer that you can do like
what right-click the backtest and and
you have code lenses and and all this
stuff it works amazingly unfortunately
it's it's bad product but it has a
couple of days of free trial so please
check it out and thank you
[Applause]